[Applaudissements]
les patristique et ouais comme s'il
s'appelle oui mais la prochaine fois on
me la met à côté toujours à créer un
petit coin et pas non mais elle m'a dit
tout à l'heure en loge elle m'a dit je
suis très content qu'il est très content
qu'ils aient patrice laffont c'est lui
qui va pour actrice la faune par rapport
à moi c'est qu'elle va dams mais moi je
sers encore ce qui se passe je sers
encore offrir un bon jour de savoir ça y
est alors les panna cotta tout ça c'est
bon ça a été cet été ahmed très bien
merci mon arbre à salins votre mari oui
toujours là embrasse aussi toujours là
pour nous regarder on embrasse très fort
à linghem beaucoup kelly vely bonsoir
bon ça comment ça va trop bien aller
bronzer celle ci c'est ça alors alors il
nous est perdu j'avais perdu du poids
oui j'ai passé mon été à éliminer le
début j'ai beaucoup énormément d'effets
buvez éliminez vous êtes avec vitaa non
j'ai éliminé la photo de ses incroyables
logement a oui ah oui on va voir des
photos de kelly vidéo payer cette année
show voir que des photos de priscilla et
lives et dvd en vacances les autres
j'aime bien mais c'est pour moi mon
délire alors ouais donc repos total les
pattes et là vous étiez sur un sur un
bateau au petit bateau ce conte pour
voir le bateau nacelle en vendée le bot
tournesol en mode et vous savez qu'il ya
pas les tournesols
ce qui pique à son nom c'est van gogh
qu'on embrasse aussi qui nous regardent
l'embrasement god japon qui est un petit
peu d'histoire à eux comment fonctionne
le sait comment il s'est coupé l'oreille
s'est coupé l'oreille lui-même et il
s'est embrouillé avec le gars il a pris
le rasoir il sait qu'on peut dire qu'il
a accrochées sur le tableau et l'aurait
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas de
peinture un récit à accrocher sur la
toile l'oreille ah oui mais bien sûr que
si les gars non non non ça c'est spock
nice vous êtes enfant pour cette année
super en forme à l'aller à l'aller à
d'abord fait peur et vous avez un petit
camarade à bout cela nord déjà un coût
même scène à ce que j'ai découvert en
allant faire l'émission d'anne roumanoff
anne roumanoff que j'embrasse et voilà
je les ai vus on s'est vus on s'est
regardés on sait j'ai demandé du taf on
va pas se mentir c'est bon on va pas se
mentir
comment il va il est très content d'être
là c'est vrai ouais il a quel âge qui
signèrent télé 16 ans d'agir troisième
il a 34 ans compte 32 32 32 ans et ben
ça fait 34 c'est pour moi c'est cadeau
j'entends bien c'est je suis très
heureux qu'il soit avec nous belges
franchement on peut l'applaudir il est
né ici
[Applaudissements]